let's go next to
ashton from california
hey dave can you hear me just barely uh
what kind of a device are you on
a really cheap headset oh all right okay
what's on your mind i'll pump up your
volume here
thanks my question is uh i know there's
a lot um
we could view the ukrainian war uh
they're the russian invasion as a net
negative obviously but i was wondering
would you
do you think that you could at least
concede there might be some positive
aspects to this war and the the thing
that i keep thinking about is
i
we hear a lot um
in the news recently especially as it
relates to like um the conservative
party in canada how because of this war
there's a lot more scrutiny coming uh
coming uh coming on to political parties
like the conservative party about the
kind of dark money that's funneled into
them and the same thing could probably
be said in the united states with uh
funding in the republican party from
certain uh russian oligarchs and whatnot
and do you think that
maybe
a silver lining in this war might be
that there's more scrutiny on that now
maybe you know if you said to me
obviously we all concede that what's
happening is terrible and there's loss
of life and destruction of uh
all sorts of things that that we hold
dear if you say can you find any silver
linings one thing that i am kind of
thinking about is
we've seen
the right in the united states
as well as you know the right in hungary
and brazil and other places really cozy
up to these dictatorial authoritarians
like putin over the last five years and
one of the silver linings of what is
happening right now i hope will be that
there will be newfound skepticism and
kind of a return to
recognizing the disaster that these
dictatorial authoritarians are so that
like if you said to me what do i think
is potentially the best silver lining it
would be that
okay yeah i agree thank you very much
all right thank you very good call very
good question